- We are back with the one
and only Dwayne Johnson.
Give it up.
(applause)
All right so as I mentioned,
Dwayne was kind enough to fly from Hawaii
to save the day on our very first show.
Here's a bit of that.
He left his honeymoon to come here,
this is real,
left his honeymoon.
His wife probably hates me.
You hadn't actually planned on being here.
Your a baby brother Kevin Hart was,
cause that's what you call him,
your baby brother he
was supposed to be here
but he was in the car
accident a few weeks ago,
so everything's good with
him now though. Right?
- Everything's good, I spoke with Kevin.
Thankfully he was strapped
in nicely to his car seat
so I think that everything.
(laughing)
- Oh my God I love you.
Well, you are a true friend of our show
and I never got a chance
to thank you properly.
So it's time to do that now people.
In Dwayne's honor,
I shipped everyone in today's audience
a bottle of his record
breaking Teremana tequila
so they all could join
me in a toast to him.
So Dwayne, do you have
any tequila with you?
- Wow. Wow yes hold on one second.
- You better.
- This is amazing.
Okay here I am.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- This is incredible.
- I know.
So wait, before we drink, wait,
what does, I'm curious,
what does the name Teremana mean?
Why did you name it that?
- Well Teremana means spirit of the earth
and it's a combination
of Latin and Polynesian.
So in tera is earth,
dirt, ground essentially.
And mana is spirit.
So mana in Polynesian
language means spirit
it comes from in here,
it's our power.
So it's a spirit of the earth.
- I would love to have
some spirit of the earth
with everyone right now.
So let's all pour a glass.
I'm down.
Okay wait, there we go.
Yeah. Cheers to you my man.
- That is a beautiful audience.
- I'm really doing it.
I am a little bummed
that I don't have like salt
and a lime, but it's fine.
Cause it's so good I don't need it right?
Let's sell this yes.
All right everybody,
it's time for a toast, but you know what?
This can't be a normal toast.
It can't be ordinary.
This is a toast to Dwayne Johnson.
Shape shifter, Demi God,
savior of the Kelly Clarkson
Show season one premiere.
Hit it guys.
(upbeat drumming)
All right, all right.
Get it, get it, get it.
Oh my that looks like a workout.
(upbeat drumming)
Oh we've got a crown.
There we go we've got a crown.
Now what the hell just happened?
That was something,
that was the parade that never ends.
- Before Kelly,
so before we do, first
of all I want to say
what a beautiful gesture.
Thank you so much for doing this Kelly.
This was an amazing surprise, thank you.
And now the world finally knows
what goes through my wife Lauren's head
after we have a sexy date night,
all of that stuff.
- That's seven from friends.
That's amazing.
All right everybody,
let's raise our glasses,
here is to the man, the myth,
the best God that's ever been,
what are you?
Are you serious?
Oh my God.
You know what,
screw it, let's drink while we can.
To Dwayne Johnson everybody.
(applause)
That's really good,
you don't need salt or a lime,
that was really good my man.
- You need no salt or lime.
- This is a good time everybody.
You should check this out,
I'm just saying.
'Young Rock' premieres tonight on NBC,
we will be right back.